after 20 years she knows your salad
thing and this is now one of the things
that I realize is that I don't know will
at all
Jada pinkett-smith has been married to
her hubby Will Smith for almost 25 years
but admits she doesn't know her husband
at all let me tell you that's been
something to be married to somebody for
20-some odd years and then realized I
don't know you and you don't know me in
the new episode of read Table Talk
titled how your relationship can survive
quarantine the host opened up about how
the corona virus pandemic has tested her
marriage I go straight to fight I'm
really kind of in a position where that
is really not the option yeah you know
what I mean and having to really just
take a breath take a minute sit on my
hands before I say or do anything that's
the thing that is difficult that people
don't understand about love you think
it's all flowers and everything but love
gets created by making it together and
that's exactly what Jada and Will are
doing now the couple has decided to take
a step back and learn how to be friends
again
the thing that will in our learning to
do is be friends yeah because you get
into all these ideas of what intimate
relationships this must look like what
marriages are supposed to be so willing
aren't in the process of him taking the
time to learn to love himself me taking
the time to learn to love myself right
and us building a friendship along the
way this isn't the first time the Smiths
have been open about their marriage
struggles him coming to the table it has
been kind of a release for him to not
have to live up to this certain Spang in
2018 will came to the table and admitted
he and Jada previously went their
separate ways we broke up within our
marriage and got back together again had
to rebuild with new rule
something way different something way
completely different but the actor says
that spending time apart from your
partner is not always a bad thing you
really have to go your separate ways to
figure out your stuff yeah you gotta be
strong enough and understand clearly
what it is you're in search for you know
what it is you want what it is you don't
want cuz that whole time when you're
when you're in a union you're pointing
fingers so I had to go away gained my
strength is Jada again not mommy not
wife and even in their lowest point Will
and Jada says divorce will never be an
option we essentially had to destroy our
marriage oh yeah she was like I can't do
this anymore and to me that was it was
over but she divorce was never even an
option I told wolfram the gate I said
let me tell you something if you marry
me know this we're gonna be together
we're gonna be under the same roof you
might be on one end of that joke about
somebody else and I always said that's
ridiculous oh we're gonna be yeah in
this joker together as for well he's
spoken candidly with et throughout the
years he shared his definition of true
love through my relationship with Jada
realized that romance actually is not
love real love is born of surviving with
someone of struggling of facing the most
insecure and inadequate parts of
yourself and struggling and suffering
where you come to a place where you
develop true love
[Music]